this morning two senate committees will
jointly hold the first hearing on the
january sixth assault on the capitol
we'll hear from the former chief of
capitol police and two other top
security officials who resigned
more than 200 people have been arrested
in the seven weeks since the riot
we know little about most of them and
how the people who raided the capitol
became radicalized ben tracy talked to a
virginia woman
struggling with her father's role at the
capitol and trying to repair
a relationship divided by politics
you know i was always close to my dad
and he was my rock you know as a kid
growing up
robin sweet is talking about her father
doug has politics always been a part of
his life
i don't ever remember as a kid anything
about politics ever
she says her dad's career at the
shipyards near his home in virginia
ended back in the early 90s when he was
injured on the job
robin's parents divorced and now doug
works as a handyman in town
was there a moment where you realized
something's really changed here
when charlottesville happened
and my dad was there the 2017 white
supremacist rally was called
unite the right she says that's when her
father fully embraced former president
trump's rhetoric
about defending confederate heritage we
will never allow an angry mob
to tear down our statues erase our
history
and doug found a new home in far-right
politics
much of it online we couldn't have a
regular conversation
that would just go right down this
rabbit hole like
they're taking children and draining
their blood
to make adrenochrome adrenochrome is a
chemical compound produced by the
oxidation of adrenaline
it's also become an ingredient in the
baseless online conspiracy theory
known as cuanon what do you say to that
at the same time robin who was 35 was
devoting herself to racial justice
issues
marching last summer with black lives
matter we're going to walk down
to the capitol then came january 6th
my very first thought was i bet my dad
is there
i was afraid for him i had people check
his facebook
he hadn't posted anything then i got
really scared
somebody sent me a news report that
listed him as arrested
doug sweet was arrested inside the
capitol i was really embarrassed
for my family for my son
for our town to understand what happened
to doug sweet
it helps to understand where he comes
from matthews virginia
a seaside town of 9 000 people we were
told by many in town that extremist and
often racist views
once hidden have been on full display in
recent years
you can't miss the confederate flags
that loom larger than any american ones
doug sweet wasn't the only person from
this small town at the capitol
he's been indicted by federal
prosecutors along with a woman named
cindy fitchett
for unlawfully entering the capitol both
have pled not guilty
i'm surprised it wasn't more really yeah
i thought it'd be more
sean cosby writes crime novels and was
born and raised in matthews
the attitudes and the ideas and the
motivations that drove people to the
capitol
have been bubbling under the surface
here since i was a kid how much of it do
you think has been a reaction to what
happened last summer with
protests for racial justice i think
that's a lot of it i think
you know i think the bottom line is you
have a lot of people
who are incredibly afraid and they can't
articulate it they know how to express
it
i didn't go with any malice or intention
of malice
this was doug swede shortly after he was
arrested what other recourse do we have
they will not listen to him we wanted to
talk to him but he declined our request
for an interview
so we went to the island where he lives
passing the largest confederate flag
we'd seen yet
and decided to see if he'd change his
mind go go right along
oh hey doug no that's not me i don't
know who you told me if you got the
wrong place
y'all go along i don't know who you all
are no doug i'm ben tracy from cbs news
doug sweet is set to appear in federal
court next month
get off the property you're on my
property all on the road so get out of
here
at the end of the day they're your
family i feel like he really
has been almost kind of brainwashed in a
way
you obviously still love him oh
absolutely
now doug sweet's own words were used by
the house managers during former
president trump's impeachment trial here
at the capitol earlier this month
they quoted him as saying that he showed
up on january 6
because the then president had called on
his digital soldiers
to be here now as for robin and her dad
she says they did get together about a
week ago
and she's hopeful they can mend their
relationship tony
ben it's a powerful piece and
representative of a lot of families in
this country and what they're going
through right now thank you very much
i mean it doesn't end it doesn't end
because these people continue to hold
these beliefs
and i don't know how you rooted out i'm
glad he's telling that story and listen
doug sweet has a right not to talk to us
he probably thinks robin's crazy for
participation absolutely
black lives matter so it would be great
to see how do you heal that divide how
do you heal it how do you bring people
back into the fold of reality as well
all right ben thank you